bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 et
sur radio france internationale nous
sommes à addis abeba en ethiopie est
notre invité pour une interview
exclusive et le ministre des affaires
étrangères algérien ramtane lamamra
monsieur le ministre bonjour bonjour
avec moi pour cette interview florence
maurice de rfi bonjour moi je vois
monsieur le ministre je veux commencer
par la situation au mali et au sahel
plus largement la france et ses
partenaires européens disent
sérieusement envisager un retrait
militaire
alors on a entendu souvent l'algérie
critiqué l'opération barkan est-ce que
la perspective de ce retrait militaire
si elle se confirme vous inquiète ou pas
du tout nous avons notre propre
perception des dynamiques en action dans
la région du sahel nous sommes d'un pays
sahélien nous sommes nous entendons
battre le curry tumultueux de cette
région et des peuples de cette région et
nous travaillons surtout d'arrache-pied
à promouvoir des solutions pacifiques
des solutions qui soient de nature à
épargner ce peuple des trams des
tragédies et je crois pouvoir le dire on
appelait ceux qui nous suivent que c'est
grâce aux efforts de l'algérie que nous
sommes parvenus à la signature par les
parties au conflit interne malien de
l'accord de paix de réconciliation au
mali issue du processus d'alger comme
son nom officiel
l'indic depuis lors gelli avec la
confiance de la communauté
internationale et de partie malienne
président d'un comité de mise en oeuvre
de suivi de cet accord d'alger qui
quinquin fait réaliste des avancées pas
au rythme souhaitable mais des avancées
quand même sur cette toile de fond
arrive des changements successifs
la tête de l'état les changements
anticonstitutionnels
naturellement les difficultés avec les
partenaires internationaux notamment la
france est à présent avec la cedeao ils
ont que l'algérie croit résolument une
solution diplomatique croit à la
concertation au dialogue et pense que
les intérêts bien compris des uns et des
autres voudraient que nous retrouvions
tous avec la bonne volonté qu'il faut le
respect mutuel qui se pose pour
envisager l'avenir de la région d'une
autre manière que conflictuelle la
communauté internationale n'a aucun
intérêt à reste à être divisé alors que
les groupes terroristes et autres
groupes de trafiquants toujours eux
savent harmoniser leurs positions et nos
actions mais ce retrait ne vous inquiète
pas écouté nous sommes très attentifs à
tout ce qui se passe dans la région et
nous considérons que l'union africaine
puisque nous sommes addis abeba devrait
pouvoir disposer des moyens et faire
preuve de la volonté politique
nécessaire pour apporter des solutions
africaines aux problèmes de l'afrique
à défaut il est naturel que des suds des
solutions alternatives comme celles qui
ont prévalu jusqu'à présent puisse avoir
lieu de sorte que les groupes
terroristes ne fasse pas qu'une bouchée
de ce grand pays de ce pays si
névralgique est si important pour la
paix la sécurité de tout toute la région
alors j'espère qu'il ya encore de
l'espace pour la raison et pour des
démarches qu'ils puissent être
respectueuse de la souveraineté
nationale du mali comme il se doit et
également
qu'elle puisse laisser place à la
communauté internationale pour que
l'assument ses responsabilités sur la
base de mandats du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies du conseil de paix et
de sécurité de l'union africaine je veux
dire il y a des solutions autant que les
faits accomplis
dans le cadre d'un retrait est ce que
l'algérie votre pays envisagera et
pourrait jouer un rôle militaire plus
direct dans le nord du mali vous savez
quoi répond généralement pas aux
questions hypothétiques
en particulier lorsqu'il s'agit de
situations très évolutive de situations
qui
se présenteront pas forcément comme une
fatalité
néanmoins j'allais vous dire aussi
néanmoins l'algérie assure déjà une part
considérable dans la stabilisation de
cette région
je vous ai dit que l'algérie était un
pays sahélien qui assume ses
responsabilités qui a des dispositifs
considérable à la fois pour la
protection de notre propre territoire
national mais aussi pour veiller à ce
que en aucune façon cette frontière
poreuse ne soient pas utilisés dans un
sens ou dans un autre en plus l'algérie
à une coopération militaire avec
l'ensemble des pays sahéliens nos
voisins coopération formation fourniture
d'équipements militaires et autres donc
j'ai demandé à l'ue de notes l'algérie
assume responsabilité à l'égard des
peuples voisins en matière de
préparation de ce pays-là faire face à
la situation telle qu'elle pourrait se
se développer alors la france et les
états unis affirment que les mercenaires
du groupe de sécurité russes wagner sont
désormais bel et bien présent au mali
est ce que vous considérez que cette
présence peut être utile dans la lutte
contre les groupes jihadistes nous
écoutons toutes les versions relations
avec eux ce développement vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que le gouvernement
malien a une autre version la situation
c'est celle que vous croyez la version
malienne c'est qu'il y à un accord avec
le gouvernement russe je crois savoir
également que c'est ce que le
gouvernement russe dit
et donc en l'occurrence il s'agit de
analyser la situation de voir les
développements et même ce point
particulier devraient être insérées dans
le contexte ensemble dont je parlais à
l'instant lorsqu'il faisait référence au
conseil de sécurité des nations-unies au
conseil de paix et sécurité de
de l'union africaine maintenant si vous
me posez la question de principe à la
poire la position de l'algérie à l'égard
de toutes les forces étrangères en
afrique je voudrais que l'autre je vous
dirais que notre position et doctrinale
qu'elle est établie une fois pour toute
et que nous sommes contre la présence de
forces étrangères quelle que soit la
nationalité sur le continent africain
ça c'est notre position doctrinale
néanmoins nous le connaissons à chaque
pays africains souverains le droit
d'organiser sa défense nationale de la
manière qui lui semble la plus
appropriée donc d'une jettera la pierre
la personne pour faire appel
qui a la france qui à la russie qui je
ne sais à qui d'autre voilà un peu la
position ce qui concerne ces
développements que je considère comme
étant conjoncturelle parce que la
situation estime seul est celle où
l'afrique assumer pleinement ses
responsabilités en matière de paix et de
sécurité
l'afrique a développé une architecture
de paix de sécurité et l'algérie un
conseiller a considérablement contribué
des sources diplomatiques africaines
affirme que votre pays aurait laissé
passer des avions militaires russes
remplis d'hommes et d'équipements est ce
que c'est le cas
écoutez la sécurité de la navigation
aérienne
n'est pas une question traitée dans des
interviews de ministre des affaires
étrangères sauf décision souveraine de
l'algérie ou d'une organisation
internationale
dans les décisions seul est obligatoire
pour les états membres le reste c'est le
principe de la liberté de la navigation
aérienne et donc
si des avions russes des avions français
les avions chinois ou autres survolent
le territoire algérien
cela ne constituerait absolument pas un
événement de nature politique il n'y a
pas d'opposition de votre part en tout
cas à acheminer des troupes et du
matériel russe et donc éventuellement
des mercenaires vers le sahel vote je ne
suis pas sûr que la qualification du
personnel soit
consensuel il ya d'autres points de vue
pour décrire les personnels en question
je ne dis pas que je préfère telle ou
telle voie du met en en répondant à
votre question qui porte ce nom je ne
voudrais pas que l'on comprenne que moi
je le reprends à mon compte d'autant
plus que le gouvernement malien dit
qu'il s'agit pas de cela gouvernement
russe non plus en l'occurrence ce que je
vous dis c'est que c'est des
épiphénomènes par rapport aux principes
nobles principes c'est que l'algérie
n'est pas en faveur du déploiement de
forces étrangères sur le continent
africain tout en respectant le droit
souverain des états concernés de faire
appel à des formes d'assistance de la
part de partenaires internationaux on va
revenir sur le terrain diplomatique
l'agente malienne a proposé une
transition maximum de cinq ans puis de 4
ans l'algérie de son côté est venu avec
une proposition de 16 mois on sait qu'il
ya des négociations
est ce qu'elle avance est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va pouvoir trouver un
compromis acceptable par tous parce
qu'on sait que la cedeao par exemple
elle ne veut entendre parler que de 6 à
10 mois par exemple
ecoutez-le encore je crois que les les
négociations les plus efficaces ne sont
pas celles qui se déroulent par médias
interposés
maintenant il ya des données que vous
avez répété cette un nombre de données
sont du domaine public l'algérie par la
voix du président de la république du
magic bull a indiqué à nos frères
maliens d'abord puis lassé des aurès la
communauté internationale que sur la
base de nos propres évaluations appuyé
par les évaluations de compétences
internationales en la matière douze à
seize mois seul et une période
raisonnable suffisante pour
l'organisation pour une gestion de la
transition de telle façon qu'ils
débouche sur des élections libres
démocratiques
techniquement incontestable nous avons
fait cette proposition publiquement le
conseil de paix et de sécurité de
l'union africaine l'a adopté
formellement
dans cette même décision
j'ai enterré les sanctions imposées par
la cdo le conseil de paix et sécurité
indique que tant que les efforts
algériennes seraient en cours il y
aurait une sorte d'effet suspensif sur
l'application des sanctions
néanmoins depuis que l'algérie a fait
ses propositions et que le conseil de
paix et de sécurité les entériner nous
attendons toujours que le gouvernement
malien et les instances compétentes
dirigeante de la cdo nous disent leur
disponibilité à participer à un dialogue
fraternel que l'algérie est disposée à
organiser non pour l'instant n'y a pas
de négociation il y a des contacts
différentes manières des gens discutent
ils compris ici à addis abeba avec tous
les ministres qui sent qu'ils sont
villes les chefs d'état qui sont en
train en train d'arriver mais il n'y a
pas de négociations à proprement parler
monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes
clairement opposés aux sanctions
décrétées par la cedeao contre la junte
au pouvoir à bamako pourtant suspendu
par l'union africaine est ce que ce
n'est pas d'une certaine manière
encourager les coups d'état et les
pouvoirs militaires dans la région mais
non maintenant
c'est à alger que l'onu a donc l'ancêtre
de de l'union africaine adoptée pour la
première fois en juillet 1999
sa première décision contre les
changements anticonstitutionnels de
gouvernement
je viens d'alger cette inspiration ne
doit pas être perdue de vue depuis lors
l'algérie a systématiquement condamner
les changements anticonstitutionnels de
gouvernement quelles que soient les
motivations
et encore l'algérie a participé à des
efforts tendant à rétablir l'ordre
constitutionnel français dans l'art et
la manière que se pose votre question
est ce que c'est par des sanctions qui
ont le potentiel de nuire de porter
préjudice
aux populations que
nous avons serions plus vite le
rétablissement de l'autre
concessionnaire ou est ce que c'est par
d'autres moyens sans doute plus
complexes sans doute plus
j'allais dire de plus doux en apparence
mais qui ont pour finalité de frais la
voie à une solution pacifique
j'ajouterai en l'occurrence puisque vous
parlez des sanctions récentes que nous
sommes avec la mauritanie les deux
grands voisins n'ont cédé au que par
principe ces deux grands pays voisins
devraient être consultés sur la manière
de travailler ensemble à régler le
problème qui se pose qui se posent à
toute la région et ça n'a pas été le cas
je ne crois pas vous le regrettez
écoutez nous sommes africains nous
sommes en afrique nous dialoguons nous
travaillons et nous pensons
que le moment arrivera bientôt nous
aurons à travailler ensemble
à aider les maliens et la cedeao à aller
de l'avant vers une solution
raisonnable qu'ils puissent dépasser
rapidement l'horizon des sanctions et
des mesures est contre et contre mesures
mais je ne laisserai pas passer
évidemment la question est ce que
l'algérie soutient directement le coup
d'état il faut surtout certainement pas
que cette idée là
reste comme étant
susceptibles d'avoir le moindre grain de
vérité nous sommes résolument dans la
doctrine de l'union africaine contre les
changements anticonstitutionnels de
gouvernement et nous décourageons les
gouvernement et nous faisons tout dans
le cadre de la prévention dans le cadre
également de nos efforts pour le
règlement des crises et conflits pour
que les peuples africains à est
résolument dans
une bonne gouvernance et puisse éliminer
toutes les causes sous jacentes qui mène
à des tensions ya des polarisations qui
rende des situations du constitutionnel
parfois parfois inévitables on peut le
déplorer
je veux en venir aux relations avec la
france oui le 29 janvier après plus de
trois mois de brouille diplomatique
les présidents macron été boon se sont
parlé ils des communiqués pour en faire
état est ce que ça veut dire que la
brouille est désormais terminé les
présidents m'agite bonne emmanuel macron
est une excellente relation personnelle
et sur téléphone parfois c'est annoncé
pour la communication du 25 janvier
parfois ce n'est pas annoncée et donc la
communication entre les deux chefs
d'état existe elle est cordiale elle est
confiante elle ne suffit pas pour
masquer l'existence de problèmes et
comme vous savez historiquement les
relations algéro françaises sont bonnes
ou mauvaises mais elles ne sont jamais
quelconque ils ne sont jamais banales
c'est la raison pour laquelle
tout le monde s'y intéresse
et c'est souvent sous la forme de
processus que ses relations la
atteignent des niveaux appréciables dans
le respect mutuel dans le respect des
souverainetés mais des niveaux
appréciables de partenariat de
coopération nous sommes aujourd'hui je
crois dans une phase
ascendante
laborieusement insolente ce qui est un
grand nombre de difficultés dans cette
relation bilatérale
singulièrement lorsqu'il s'agit en ce
qui nous concerne de la protection et de
la préservation de la sécurité de la
dignité de nos compatriotes en
territoire un territoire français c'est
un sujet auquel nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles mais a tenté
également
sujet qui j'allais dire ils sont
quantifiables ouais donc des solutions
de compromis sont toujours possibles
mais lorsqu'il s'agit d' atteinte à la
mémoire d'un fait à l'histoire ou à la
dignité du peuple algérien ou deux
compatriotes installés au voyage en
france ceux ci constituent souvent des
motifs très sérieux de difficultés dans
les relations mais ça va mieux mais
disons que nous sommes dans la phase
ascendante et que nous espérons que ça y
est là debout de mieux en mieux alors
juste concrètement le président français
a invité à nouveau le président tebboune
à venir assister au sommet qui doit se
tenir mi février à bruxelles entre
l'union africaine et l'union européenne
est ce que le président tebboune va se
rendre à ce sommet à bruxelles à ce
stade je n'exclus rien
je n'excluerais
voulez vous voulez des réponses courtes
clair
vous l'évoquiez à l'instant elle la
france a réduit le nombre de visas
accordés aux algériens elle affirme que
l'algérie refuse de son côté
d'accueillir les algériens expulsables
de france est-ce que sur ce dossier on
peut envisager un compromis entre les
deux pays voyez cela fait partie aussi
des malentendus que peut-être certaines
déclarations à la presse du côté
français naturellement amplifie hors
proportion est dans l'impression qu'il
s'agit d'un d'une divergence majeure
la géline ne protège pas des personnes
qui violent la loi français de la même
manière qu aucun état ne devrait
protéger des gens qui violent la loi
algérienne ceux-ci ceci est clair
néanmoins lorsque nous parlons de
circulation d'établissement des
personnes il ya eu certaines sélectivité
du côté français en laisse libres de
leurs mouvements cette catégorie de
personnes et qui pourtant
j'allais dire post-it eu parfois des
menaces à la sécurité nationale de
l'algérie pendant que d'autres âmes qui
sont là à la recherche d'un emploi ou
qui ont été justement amenée en france
dans le cadre d'accords de main d'oeuvre
et en hauteur depuis longtemps se
retrouve du jour au lendemain concernés
par des mesures
d'éloignement du territoire national
français
lorsqu'il s'agit de questions humaines
nous considérons qu'il faut les traiter
humainement il faut et naturellement que
la loi soit appliquée mais qu'elle soit
appliquée de manière non sélective et
qu'elle puisse se reposer sur un minimum
j'allais dire de respect à la dignité de
la personne humaine donc dans la
discussion avec les autorités françaises
nous veillons à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
charter d'ailleurs charles terre nous
veillons à ce que les gens bénéficient
des recours possible devant les
autorités françaises avant qu'elle soit
reconduite aux frontières
et en cela les autorités algériennes
veille véritablement à ce que ces
accords agit au français soit exécutée
mais exécuté de manière convenable donc
il est faux de dire que nous refusons de
recevoir nos compatriotes qui n'ont plus
rien à faire le territoire en territoire
français pour vous ayez un recours
excessif en fait de la france à ces
expulsions
écouter lorsque certains annoncent
publiquement qu'il faut faire du chiffre
c'est clair qu'il y à déjà vu
est-ce que autre exemple peut-être
concrets de rapprochement vous dites on
est dans une phase ascendante
est-ce que vous allez autorisé à nouveau
les avions militaires français a
traversé l'espace aérien pour se rendre
au sahel on sait que la france a
regretté cette décision suite à la
brouille est ce que dorénavant vous avez
de nouveau autorisé il s'agit d'une
mesure technique symbolique environ
mesures techniques qui n'a pas vocation
à durer éternellement
la situation est ce qu'elle est dépend
de la coopération algéro françaises sont
en train de se remettre en place et donc
cette question ne doit pas être
traité comme étant quelque chose
d'éminemment politique où c'était une
décision symbolique religieuse monsieur
le ministre a donc là vous êtes en train
de dire ça va être rétablie ou que c'est
en train de l'être
je pense que c'est une d'incompréhension
correcte de la dynamique de de ce que
j'appelle la phase ascendante
de la relation algéro-française alors
sur les questions mémorielles on sait
que emmanuel macron s'y est intéressé
beaucoup c'est un sujet de discussion
avec le président teboul le communiqué
de l'élite l'idée parle d'ailleurs
d'apaiser les mémoires récemment je vais
juste prendre un exemple emmanuel macron
a exhorté les autorités algériennes à
reconnaître et je le cite regarder en
face le massacre du 5 juillet 1962 à
oran des centaines d'européens beaucoup
de français ont été tués on n'a pas
entendu de réaction algérienne
nous en donne l'occasion écoutez si l'on
devait rouvrir ses chapitres de
l'histoire et traiter des massacres à
travers l'histoire les massacres
perpétrés par la france coloniale en
algérie certains ont connu d'autres ne
l'étant pas il y aurait de quoi remplir
beaucoup de livres d'histoire
le
chef de l'état français dans des
circonstances particulières a fait les
déclarations que que vous indiquez
nous pensons que l'histoire doit être
laissé aux historiens mais que cela doit
se faire dans la sérénité et que cette
appropriation par chacun des peuples
concernés de son histoire devrait se
faire dans toute la mesure du possible
sans acrimonie et sont
des accusations
que qui ne sont pas forcément avérée est
dans son rôle donc maintenant il sort de
son rôle non je ne porte pas un jugement
sur ce que fait ou ne fait pas le
président de la république française il
s'agit pas cela je dis simplement que
cette histoire commune est trop délicat
trop fragile pour que nous prenions de
manière très sélective un événement bâti
culié et que nous prenions une
interprétation particulière de la
signification et de la portée de
l'événement en question séparée de tout
un processus historique et de beaucoup
de d'événements similaires ont
malheureusement le sang des algériens a
été a été versé en abondance alors que
nous regardons l'avenir je pense que le
respect mutuel voudrait précisément que
qui n'est pas d'accusation
inutile
superfétatoire et que nous regardions
plutôt l'avenir ensemble avec une vision
optimiste de cet avenir de vision ou les
intérêts communs en tant que tout ce qui
est de nature à promouvoir une
convivialité harmonieuse un partenariat
équilibré entre les deux pays et la
priorité dans nos déclarations et dans
nos interactions le président bak rond
avait notamment fâché votre pays en
déclarant je le cite un est ce qu'il y
avait une nation algérienne avant la
colonisation française ça c'est la
question il s'est il expliqué voir
excusé de ses propos auprès du président
tebboune je suis tenté de dire que s'il
n'y avait pas eu de nation avant la
colonisation française il n'y aurait pas
une colonisation française c'est parce
que la nation algérienne et elle a été
productive active entreprenante aux
portes de la france à travers la
méditerranée c'est parce que des
livraisons des cargaisons de blé n'ont
pas été payés en temps et en heure que
des conflits des difficultés sont
apparues dans les relations entre les
autorités algériennes de l'époque que
les autorités françaises de l'époque
est-ce que les deux présidents ont eu
l'occasion de s'en expliquer
je ne suis pas forcément présent à
chacune de leurs communications
téléphoniques
j'imagine mais c'était quand même un
point très important c'est très
important mais je ne suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs à moins que vous a donné la
preuve que le président mac rae dit
exactement ce que vous rapportez je ne
suis pas très sûr de cela mais la
question c'est pas la question qui est
posée aujourd'hui
juste brièvement pour clore ce chapitre
franco-algérien même s'il y aurait
encore beaucoup à dire
bientôt il y aura là la commémoration
des accords d'evian est ce que vous
espérez un geste de la france on sait
que l'algérie demande par exemple la
restitution des archives je peux pas
faire toute la liste mais est-ce que
vous pensez que ce sera important que la
france fasse un geste pour cette date
symbolique il ya un certain nombre
d'actions qui ont été prises par le
président emmanuel mac en jeu négligeait
pas ses actions comme étant des gestes
mais des situations tout à fait normal
dans deux entre deux pays amis qui
aspirent à bâtir une relation
qualitative différente de ce qui a été
l'histoire tumultueuse de leurs
relations bilatérales
dans ce cadre là et un certain nombre
d'accords comme en ce qui concerne
l'institution archives encore faut-il
lorsqu'on avance le principe
voir ce qu'il y a exactement dans le
contenu est ce que ce sont toutes les
archives achieve de souveraineté les
archives indispensable au développement
du pays ou est ce qu'il y à une
sélectivité et vous suivez l'actualité
et vous savez très bien que ce ne sont
pas toutes les archives qui pourraient
être restitués à l'état à l'état
algérien et un certain nombre d'autres
objets symboliques qui sont un peu
partout à brest et ailleurs donc
l'effort doit être poursuivi l'effort
doit être poursuivie et l'algérie doit
être mise en mesure de récupérer des
objets importants de son patrimoine
national qui se trouve dans une
situation anormale en étant loin de ce
territoire algérien c'est l'histoire
vous me direz mais la cohérence de
l'histoire voudrait que l'indépendance
de l'algérie chèrement reconquise
s'accompagne de la réappropriation de
tous les biens matériels immatériels qui
sont les siens et qui ont été déplacés
et dans certains autorités certaines
personnes physiques ou morales français
se sont appropriés j'espère que ce
j'espère nous demandons que ce processus
se poursuivrait de l'avant comme fois
dans l'amitié dans le respect mutuel et
ceci n'est pas propre d'ailleurs la
relation à méreau française dans
beaucoup de cas il y à ce phénomène de
restitution cela se fait dans la bonne
entente parce que il y va véritablement
d' du respect mutuel que deux nations
doivent
ce témoigner pour l'assumer de
l'histoire commune vous souhaitez la
restitution d'un bien précis en
particulier
vient priver d'un bien précis vous
souhaitez la récitation la restitution
nous avons un canon histoire inquiète à
brest nous avons beaucoup de choses nous
avons beaucoup choses les archives nous
avons hélas même quelques crânes de deux
héros de la résistance algérienne contre
l'invasion française on se demande
d'ailleurs si c'est vraiment
civilisé que de garder dans des musées
les crânes de résistants algériens
dont on fait des trophées
cela pouvait s'expliquer à l'époque de
la montée du colonialisme mais pas l'ère
des indépendances et de la souveraineté
des peuples donc plus vite nous réglons
en fait tout ce qui est l'héritage de la
guerre de libération nationale
par rapport à
l'état français mieux cela ira dans la
manière de cohabiter de coexister de
développer un partenariat mutuellement
avantageux
alors si les relations semblent se
réchauffer avec paris sur une phase
ascendante dites vous ce n'est pas le
cas avec rabat votre voisin depuis la
rupture diplomatique il y a 6 mois
maintenant certains craignent même qu'on
se dirige vers une guerre est ce que
c'est votre cas aussi
je pense que les relations avec le maroc
voisin ne se sont pas dégradés juste à
la faveur de la décision de l'algérie de
rompre les relations diplomatiques
la rupture des relations diplomatiques a
été le couronnement d'un processus de
dégradation de cette relation avec la
partie marocaine
maintenant une véritable guerre de
quatrième génération à la nation
algérien je n'entrais pas dans le détail
le temps qui nous est imparti et en est
en cours et donc eu une
explosion était était là nul ne pouvait
la stopper face à la dégradation cette
situation et dans sa sagesse l'algérie a
opté pour
la lecture des relations diplomatiques
ce qui est un acte civilisé qui se
trouvent dans l'est dans les pratiques
des de tout de tout les nations du monde
et donc nous vivons sans relations
diplomatiques ce n'est pas la première
fois que ça nous arrive c'est déjà
arrivé à l'initiative de la partie
française de la partie marocaine dans le
passé et à l'initiative de la partie
algérienne
cette fois ci il ya des problèmes dans
ma région la solution à ce problème ne
réside pas dans la fuite en avant telle
que celle qui consiste à inviter des
dirigeants israéliens qui viennent à nos
frontières menace et l'algérie à partir
du territoire marocain ou celle qui
consiste à développer des des slows bon
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la réalité à
faire assumer cela par un appareil de
propagande
qui ne recule devant aucune calomnie est
donc cette situation là c'est ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui
mais rassurez vous l'algérie ne ferait
fera la guerre pour légitime défense
l'algérie a trop connu les affres de la
guerre coloniale justement vous souhaité
s'engager dans une confrontation armée
avec un pays voisin il faut se demander
si ce qui développe des coopérations
militaires avec des puissances
militaires étrangères n'ayant rien à
voir avec la région nord africaine ne
sont pas ceux qui parient sur le pij
alors justement de ce que vous voyez
côté marocain est ce que vous avez
l'impression que le maroc lui envient
peut-être de faire la guerre écoutez je
ne suis pas là pour détecter les
intentions pour l'analyser
ddd des propos des manipulations on
parle d'opération militaire je serais tu
seulement je constate seulement qu'il y
a kylie à cette escalade de la part des
autorités disent tous les marocains
c'est une réalité
des importations massives d'armement des
des alliances militaires d'un type
nouveau
voilà ce qu'est ce qui est la réalité
malheureusement à nos frontières nos
frontières nationales
le journal africa intelligence part
notamment de ventes de drones d'attaqué
au maroc de la part d'israël est ce que
votre voisin n'est pas désormais
supérieures militairement notamment
depuis qu'il peut compter sur le soutien
d'israël
je pense que c'est le calcul qui est
fait du côté de rabat malheureusement
mais il ya beaucoup de calculs erronés
et c'est sous-estimer
l'algérie le peuple algérien l'histoire
de la jcch de croire que de telles
gesticulations pourrait nous
impressionner ans pour le moins nous
intimider alors l'administration trump a
reconnu la marocanité du sahara c'était
un coup dur c'était une erreur
historique mais une erreur historique
que visiblement de l'administration
byden confirme parce qu'elle n'est pas
revenu sur cette décision et c'est plus
subtil que cela c'est plus subtil mêlée
mais ils ne sont pas revenus dessus
anthony blinken a même déclaré que le
plan d'autonomie du maroc le site est
sérieux crédible et réaliste ce donc ce
camouflet n'a pas été effacés ces trois
qualificatifs appartiennent à la
littérature de certains membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité depuis
2007 ce n'est pas nouveau
ça date de 2007 ce en s'entraidant nom
dans l'histoire néanmoins ce que l'on
constate aujourd'hui c'est que
l'administration américaine soutient
monsieur t me saoule à l'envoyé spécial
des personnels disquettes générale des
nations unies que les états unis sont
toujours le porte plume pour la
rédaction de la résolution du conseil de
sécurité sur le sahara occidental est
que cette littérature du conseil de
sécurité la suze unis disposent toujours
qu'un une solution mutuellement
acceptable
pour les deux parties front polisario
république sahraouie et royaume du maroc
solution acceptable par les deux
assurent en garantissant le droit à
l'autodétermination du peuple du sahara
occidental c'est cela la position des
nations unies et c'est cela la position
des monts permanent et notamment et vous
souhaitez quand même que les états unis
reviennent sur leur position vous avez
pas me dire que ça vous est totalement
indifférent non pas du tout nous
considérons que la décision qui a été
annoncée par l'ancien président
trempette et erronées étaient faites
pour des considérations autres que les
la valeur juridique humaine politique du
dossier sahraoui et que cette décision
là j'allais dire je ne grandit pas
l'administration trempe cela fait même
partie j'allais dire j'ai du bilan
négatif de l'administration trompe mais
alors par ailleurs une vingtaine de pays
africains et arabes ont ouvert des
consulats ou représentation diplomatique
au sahara occidental est ce que le maroc
n'est pas tout simplement en train de
gagner la partie diplomatiquement sur ce
dossier les consulats dans les parties
occupées du sahara occidental sont une
vaste mystification
d'abord au plan juridique sans signifie
absolument rien ce n'est pas un consulat
qui vous donne souveraineté souveraineté
appartient au peuple du sahara
occidental qu'il exerce à travers un
référendum d'autodétermination
c'est bien au-dessus politique ferme les
fossiles en question c'est un geste
propagande qui perdent fort qui peut
être fort mais ça reste un geste
propagande qui n'a aucune portée
juridique ou politique
on accroche une plaque à un mur on
déclare qu'il s'agit là d'un consulat de
pays qui n'ont absolument aucun
ressortissant dans l'espace sahraoui et
de pays qui n'ont pas l'intention de
jouer un rôle ni économique ni politique
n'est autre ni l'intention ni parfois
les moyens de jouer un rôle dans le
territoire du sahara occidental
c'est une mystification c'est de la
propagande ça ne va pas plus loin que ça
rapidement le ministre parce qu'on
arrive vers la fin de cet entretien
il ya une question qui agite beaucoup
dans les capitales arabes c'est le
sommet de la ligue arabe il devait avoir
lieu en algérie il a été reporté alors
une question à ce qu'il aura bien lieu
en algérie et est ce qu'il aura lieu
comme il se murmure le 1er novembre il
aura bien lieu en algérie l'algérie
développe un mécanisme de consultation
assez original assez inédit nous parlons
à beaucoup de monde les états membres
naturellement mais aussi l'opinion
publique arabe les entités
palestiniennes
non représentés dans nos alpes étant
entendu que le président de beaune a
lancé tout ce processus après
consultation avec le président mahmoud
abbas ali dans la palestine lorsqu'il a
visité l'algérie et nous souhaitons
véritablement à réunir toutes les
conditions du succès historiquement les
sommets arabes qui sont tenus à alger
ont été de grands moments pour
l'histoire non seulement d'algérie mais
de tout le monde rame vous laisse toi de
la palestine nous souhaitons
véritablement que le prochain sommet qui
quels le président est bonne accordent
un intérêt personnel mais aussi un
intérêt historique soit véritablement
j'allais dire sans précédent vu tout
tous les défis qui assaillent le monde
arabe et vu toutes les interpellations
de nos opinions publiques et de nos
peuples nous souhaitons temps qu'un
sursaut de la conscience un éveil de la
conscience des uns et des autres un
sursaut collectif pour faire en sorte
que nous puissions ouvrir de meilleurs
horizons à nos peuples quels que soient
par ailleurs les divergences bilatérales
qu'il peut y avoir entre tel et tel pays
participants le poids le fait est que
nous avons des intérêts collectifs
nous avons l'obligation de continuer à
assumer un devoir de solidarité envers
la palestine le peuple palestinien et
nous croyons nous en algérie qu'à la
faveur de cette
préparation intensive et intense que
nous parviendrons à avoir un tel sommet
qui soit véritablement
temps fort pour le monde arabe et la
communauté internationale novembre je
m'empresse d'ajouter que le sommet en
question sur un sommet qui renforcera
les chances de la paix au moyen orient
probablement en bâtissant sur
l'initiative arabe de paix du sommet de
beyrouth de 2002 et que ce sera un
sommet de la responsabilité un sommet de
l'unité de la responsabilité
un sommet où
la communauté internationale sera
appelée à assumer quand même un devoir
de vérité envers la paix au moyen orient
s'agit pas de continuer à faire comme si
il il pourrait voir un oubli ou que la
question de palestine où les conditions
réelles de la paix par la libération de
tous les territoires arabes occupés
qu'ils sont à conditions d'une paix
réelle d'une paix durable
c'est facile et simplement parce qu'il y
aurait un phénomène de péremption de
cette revendication légitime mais ce
n'est pas le cas le 1er novembre et
innovant le 1er novembre est une grande
date historique un grand moment pour les
algériens comme pour tous les peuples
arabes auxquels le 1er novembre a rendu
la fierté a vendu beaucoup de et donc le
1er novembre c'est une c'est une c'est
une date marquante de l'histoire de
l'algérie de l'histoire du monde arabe
et du monde tout court néanmoins c'est
le 9 mars prochain que le conseil des
ministres de la ligue arabe sera saisi
de la date que le président de bonnevoie
l'a arrêté gilles a déjà arrêté et qui
sera donc entériné par le sommet par la
réunion ministérielle de la ligue arabe
laissez-moi ajouté que le président de
bouna adressé des messages un certain
nombre de ses homologues arabes et que
sa démarche est partout considéré comme
étant rationnels comme étant sérieuse et
comme étant garante du succès de cette
phase importante de l'action arabe
commune
en juillet dernier monsieur le ministre
le président de la commission de l'union
africaine moussa faki à accorder à
israël statut d'observateur ici à
l'union africaine vous vous y opposer
vigoureusement vous avez fait inscrire
cette question à l'ordre du jour du
sommet des chefs d'état de ce week end
est ce que le continent n'a pas d'autres
priorités actuellement entre le co vide
les coups d'état qui se multiplient les
conflits se question qui se pose vous
avez raison de la pause et mais pas moi
nous n'avons pas pris l'initiative
d'accorder un quelconque statut
d'observateur à quiconque
il y a une double faute si vous le
permettez en l'occurrence celle d'avoir
accordé un statut d'observateur sans
aucune consultation avec les états
membres dans l'algérie et lorsque je dis
cela c'est le statut d'observateur à
quiconque la loi et demander s'agit pas
spécifiquement de ce cas là ça pourrait
être une ong ça pourrait être un autre
pays et sert à ça c'est la première
faute c'est une prérogative
avec consultation des textes de l'union
africaine sont très claires il faut
consulter et combien même quand bien
même il s'agirait de poudre de
prérogatives appartenant tout
particulièrement à une autorité
particulière de l'organisation vous
assumez vos responsabilités
en ayant en conscience les effets de
votre décision si votre décision a pour
effet inévitable de diviser vos
organisations
sur laquelle vous avez le devoir de
veiller cela signifie que la décision
est mauvaise et qu'il ne faut pas la
prendre en l'occurrence si les
consultations préalables avaient eu lieu
sans doute
nous arrêtons pas pris une telle
décision la deuxième faute des juges ont
également c'est d'avoir constaté que les
états membres sont divisés sur cette
question et de la laisser j'allais dire
jeux 2d grainé ceci est très mauvais
pour l'organisation et donc
indépendamment de qui a fait quoi au
profit de qui ou de quoi le fait est que
ma décision en question est une décision
met en péril la solidarité qui doit
exister entre les pays membres
d'organisations j'ajouterai ans nous
fait l'honneur de dire l'algérie a
inscrit l'algérie et l'afrique du sud
d'avoir pour parler spécifiquement de ce
qui s'est passé de ce qui se passe à la
présente réunion aura ensuite pendant le
débat
tous les pays nord-africains de la
mauritanie jusqu à l'egypte à
l'exception d'un seul pays vous l'aurez
deviné le maroc tous ces pays là se sont
opposés à ce statut d'observateur et un
grand nombre de pays subsahariens il
construit des pays subsahariens qui ont
des relations diplomatiques avec israël
se sont opposées à l'octroi du statut
d'observateur à israël du sud le nigeria
et d'autres
vous comprendrez donc il s'agit d'une
question institutionnelle politique et
pour certains stratégique voilà de quoi
il s'agit je crois que la question est
parfaitement clair
nous avons en tant que membre
responsable de l'union africaine le
devoir de dire ceci est juste ceux ci
l'ait pas telle décision est appropriée
telle décision ne l'est pas en
l'occurrence pour me résumer du double
point de vue de la légalité
et de l'opportunité politique la
décision est erronée
merci monsieur le ministre et merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi sur nos deux
antennes
[Musique]